really bizarre story to tell you about
Steve Bannon Trump's chief strategist
and sort of propagandist and chief is
fat-shaming outgoing press secretary
Sean Spicer Spicer is reportedly being
considered for a different position at
the White House as I told you yesterday
which would take him out of his job as
press secretary and giving those daily
briefings to the White House press corps
and Spicer has been holding more and
more of the press briefings without
cameras in the room and reportedly two
days ago actually held them without
cameras or audio recording in the room
which sort of defeats the purpose no one
at the White House has commented on this
new format for the briefings except for
Steve Bannon he was asked by a reporter
at the Atlantic why Sean Spicer hasn't
been allowing cameras into the room
Bannon texted back a response to the
Atlantic saying merely Shawn got fatter
suggesting that alleged increases to the
weight of Sean Spicer have made him not
want to be on camera Bannon did not
respond to a follow-up that's all he
said he also didn't say Shawn got fat he
said Shawn got fatter this is odd on a
number of levels it's odd because Steve
Bannon isn't exactly a skinny guy right
I mean neither is Donald Trump I'll
remind you if you're watching Steve
Bannon is sort of a portly fellow as
well and and this isn't about responding
to bannon's fat shaming by fat shaming
him but just to sort of be aware of the
hypocrisy and Steve Bannon is also quite
a bit bigger than Spicer I mean we've
got a freeze-frame of Sean Spicer to
show our TV audience from a recent video
this is sort of like when Trump kept fat
shaming Rosie O'Donnell doesn't really
make sense maybe it was a joke we don't
know for sure if Bannon was joking maybe
he'd follow up to make sure that the
reporter knew it was a joke but this is
really really odd and Bannon seems to
have touched on the sort of third rail
of American politics which is if there's
one thing people in the u.s. can agree
on it is our right to be overweight yeah
I mean we can't all be as handsome and
fit as Steve Bannon is now of what I
thought of was where are you in your
head where are you emotional
wait where you think to send a message
like that even if I thought this is
something I want to communicate I
wouldn't send a message like that to a
friend about someone we both dislike for
fear that it could be screenshotted and
published at some point
never mind sending that text to a
reporter about a colleague is it
possible though that Steve Bannon was
just trolling here like he didn't want
to answer the question as to why cameras
weren't allowed in the briefing room
right so he just wanted to kind of
facetiously shrug it aside the answer he
could have just not answered it the way
no one else at the Trump White House has
but he also might be a practicing the
expert add the expert act of distraction
to appeal to us progressives to feel
badly for Sean Spicer instead of the
truth that Spicer is being pushed out
because he's a train wreck
he made us want to think he's fat
shaming Sean Spicer and that's a really
mean thing to do it could be Steve
Bannon being a total and utter genius I
don't know I guess the jury's out on
that